the jurgen experience wreck
formula too between the percentage of
humidity and then the increased
temperature the way it feels like if
it's at 180 but you have 10 percent
humidity it's like feels like yeah there
is i don't know what that formula is
absolutely there's a formula and in a
lot of the studies and coming out of
finland
um many of the people there are using
are doing the the humid stuff on saunas
as well
so i mean i guess they're called finnish
saunas which means like
they're using the the hot water and
steam it would be amazing to have a
sauna
outside sauna that's right next to a
frozen lake like the way they do it oh
yeah they cut a hole in the lake and
then get the party stuff so what we did
i went i visited the sauna society
and um it was in november so it was cold
and um it's right on a lake and so they
have like
the day i went it was not co-ed day so
um
the you know it's only women saunas that
i went in there's like he was like
sectioned off
but so you go and you do these different
they have all these different types and
i don't remember and they're like
whipping each other with like
birchwood you know yeah which um
yeah the russians like to do that they
call it the bonya right the russian bomb
yeah
they beat each other with this these
branches that are wet
so okay let me tell you my stroke
anyways they jump in the lake and then
they go back and they're doing this
right so here's my
did i ever tell you my crazy story story
about family that's a crazy story
so i have a there's a friend he's a
friend he's you know he's
some of your friends are a little
eccentric right well this guy he's got
he's got a you know huge um property in
in like the country in the woods like in
finland
and it's like the first time i ever went
camping and it was like snow camping
it was crazy it was like the worst thing
ever like he had
he had us do this like there was like
two tents
and and it was a conference that i gave
a talk at and so there some people paid
extra to like go to this
event that that was after it so there
was like 30 or so people there
and they were from all around the world
there was only like three americans
me dan and some other guy no four
americans i think
but anyways um it was my first time
camping like outside like not in like
like i've been to yosemite but i like
stay in a cabin you know i don't like
sleep in a tent but so it wasn't a great
experience because
one there was this guy who snored all
night
two because it was snow camping we had
to like there was some weird
fire thing and he was this guy was in
the military
and so he had us do this thing where
like everyone had to wake up but
i forgot what it was every hour
someone's you had to pass this thing
in a big wall tent we were in a big i
don't know what it was called but i
didn't sleep the whole night and it was
awful
oh but here's my sauna experience so
he um doesn't believe in you can't wear
like swimsuits or anything
in the sauna so you have to be like you
have to wear no clothes or
if you if you really wanted you could
wear a towel like if you were
modest or whatever because to them it's
like oh no big deal the sauna you just
you don't wear any clothes
okay so they were i know they told me
they told me oh no the sauna is an
asexual place and i'm like really
really you're a human being i know so so
so only three people wore a towel me dan
and this other american
and so everyone was in there naked lots
of like there weren't that many females
um but there were some from i don't know
the uk
or in some german i don't know but they
were all naked like it was like i guess
europeans are like that you know like
they're more used to it or that's what
someone was told me i don't know what
the what the case is but anyways
i had people coming up to me going i
love your podcasts and this
i'm like i'm not gonna get naked before
like at the conference and they were
there and you like you think i'm gonna
be naked like in this sauna with someone
who's like
a podcast fan yes oh my god they're in
your face
so anyways i'm in the sauna everyone's
naked and then
he the and the guy who's my friend okay
he's still my friend
he's he's an interesting guy but he had
like
people come and started doing yoga so
and they're naked too
jesus people are totally naked they're
doing good they're doing
this naked wonderful so that was
like my my first finnish sauna
experience where it was like people
are too open-minded they really are when
it comes to things like that i was just
happy he was like you can wear a towel
if you want
because he hasn't i wouldn't do it i'm
like get out of here you're not staring
at my chunk
yeah so then i went they were all
jumping in the lake after and i'm like
i'm gonna just sit on this patio it's
freezing out here in finland in november
i'm not gonna take my towel off and jump
in the the lake forev
like forever why can't you wear a
swimsuit why says who
like what is the difference there's zero
difference in the benefits of it claims
it's a cultural thing and also he
claimed that there's like toxins being
released from
oh one of those [ __ ] [ __ ] off buddy
i got a swimsuit on
and then okay the yoga was bad it got
worse then he had some
he had some whipping technique with the
birch wood and he wanted like to
demonstrate it so he had like one of the
britain girls like
and she was laying i mean it was just
like it was too much
here's the here's the truth like i was
hot as [ __ ]
right so all like i didn't care anymore
like i cared about my towel but i didn't
care what was going on i was trying not
to look at everyone you know like i
didn't want to see
like you know i'm married like i don't
see everyone's
stuff well people get sexual too because
it's hot and sweaty
and if this guy's like it sounds like
he's a little a bit of a cult leader
right like someone needs to be naked
okay
that's someone was asking me that
because he passed out like this flyer
because like we were doing all these
events you know all these events were
happening and this flyer passed out and
was like
we're reading it and i was like it says
you have to you can't wear any clothes
or swimsuit or anything because i had
packed my swimsuit i was like yeah i'm
gonna wear my swimsuit in the sauna you
know
you can't tell people they can't wear
clothes you just lose his own home sauna
you know
yeah how convenient but you could wear a
towel
so great thanks buddy
you